ليس واقعيا متعجرف هذه بعض من الاوصاف
التي اجتاحت الوسط السياسي المعارضه في
فرنسا بعد كلام الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرو
وحديثه عن تمسكه بقانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد
مره جديده يتحدث رئيس الجمهوريه لكي لا
يقول شيئا ومما فهمناه نجد فقط علامات
الازدراء التقليديه التي ما يزال يرهقنا
بها الى الان
تتفق معه زعيمه اقصى اليمين مارين لوبان
دور الرئيس هو مخاطبه الجميع من دون
اقصاءنا وازدراء لايجاد الكلمات التي
تطمئن وتوحد اليوم عزز السيد مكرون شعوره
لزراء لجزء من الناس شعور الازدراء هذا
انسحب على الشارع حيث تسيطر شريحه الطلاب
عليهم منذ سته ايام ما دفع ماكرون لوصف
تحركهم بانه غير شرعي فبدات عمليات عصيان
في الجامعات وصل عددها الان الى 60 جامعه
في كل فرنسا وهو تحرك انطلق من جامعه
السوربون التي طوقتها الشرطه اعلم في
العاده ننسق تحركاتنا مع النقابات لكننا
الان نتحرك من تلقاء انفسنا لان الشباب
فهموا انه اذا لم يتحركوا من اجل مستقبلهم
فلن يتحرك احد من اجلهم خلال الحديث مع
ريتشي استوقفنا جاره الكهل مثنيا على تحرك
الطلاب في الشارع ومعتبرا ان الشعب هو
القانون وليس ما يحاول ماكرون تطبيقه
الشباب يبعثون الخوف في قلب السلطه كبار
السن مثلي يمكن اسكاتهم لكن الشباب لا
يمكن السيطره عليهم
عدم سيطره الشرطه على احتجاجات الشباب كان
واضحا من خلال تمكنهم من تحويل ليل فرنسا
الى نهار فراحوا يشعلون الحرائق في
الشوارع وهذا ليس الافتعال الشغب كما
يقولون وانما لعرقله الشرطه التي تلهث
خلفهم وتخاطر بان يكون الوضع اسوا عندما
سيجتمع هؤلاء الطلاب مع النقابيين الذين
اعدوا العده للخميس الاسود
فدهوك العربيه باريس